♪♪♪
- Jordan Love, is he underrated?
- [Jordan Love:] I just got something to prove today.
- [Adam Lefkoe:] Mmm.
-  Hut.
♪♪♪
- [Clint Oldenburg:] Ooh, that was good avoidance.
- There we go.
- [Lefkoe cheering]
♪♪♪
- Welcome to "Underrated,"
the only show that prides itself
on improving the video game
ratings of professional athletes.
And you may notice the guy who is wearing
the exact same clothes behind me.
Yeah, that's Jordan Love,
quarterback of the Green Bay Packers.
Why are we wearing all black?
Cuz it's a funeral
for the haters. Why?
Because Jordan Love is wildly underrated.
And we're gonna fix that
today. Isn't that right, Jordan Love?
- Yessir, twin.
- Twin.
Let's get more on Jordan Love's
ability as a player in Madden.
Let's go to our pro gamer, YoBoy PIZZA.
- Interestingly enough,
we're about to do something that,
I don't know, probably not
many people would think about doing.
Jordan Love at punter.
Look, this guy's an athlete.
He could do it all over the field.
Obviously, he can throw the ball.
He claims he could punt, though.
He was a punter in high school, I believe.
You know, that should
replicate a little bit here
whenever it comes to Madden, right?
All right, it looks like we've
got the power and accuracy.
Where's the hang time on that?
That went 10 yards.
- Have you ever been
an emergency punter before?
I mean, high school,
you know, did a little quarterback punt,
scoot back a little bit and have the quarterback punt it.
- Yeah?
- [Lefkoe:] Kick accuracy, what do you think you are?
- Oof, 42. [Ding]
- An 18. [Buzzer]
- Mm, that's tough.
- Yeah.
- You never like to see that.
- I have a guy.
I want you to meet this guy.
This guy can improve your Madden ratings.
Clint Oldenburg, please come out here.
♪​​♪♪
Clint, Jordan. Jordan, Clint.
Where does he rank as a quarterback
that punts?
- Kick power currently 33 and kick accuracy for you 18.
That is then 31 among all quarterbacks,
- I just got something to prove today, you know?
- Mmm.
- That's all I got.
- This is the guy that can get it done.
- Yep.
- [Lefkoe:] You heard it here first.
State Farm offers surprisingly great rates.
Now let's give Jordan Love a chance
to show he deserves
a surprisingly great kick accuracy rate.
This is, like, the classic coffin
corner Madden drill.
So that means if you get it in the orange
10 times, your kick rating is going up 30.
- I'm aiming for that right now.
♪♪♪
- Clint, you ready?
- [Oldenburg:] Ready.
- Jordan, time is yours.
- OK.
Great lift, and it is...in the blue.
Now that's two!
That was beautiful.
- [Jordan Love:] No. 2.
- [Lefkoe:] Oh, and that, that's gonna hit a car.
And it did. It hit a Ford Escape. I hope…
- [Laughing offscreen]
- [Lefkoe:] Was that your car?
- No, it's not my car.
I don't know whose car that is, and.
- But we'd like to formally apologize to them.
- I would definitely like to apologize.
♪♪♪
- [Lefkoe:] Good lift. Bang! Three. Wow.
Oh, and this one is
straight down the middle.
- Winds gonna pick him up.
- Oh, oh!
Oh, so that's going to be minus one.
This is the lastone.
- [Love:] Last one? OK.
- [Lefkoe:] You're at plus-six.
- [Love sighing] Here we go.
- [Lefkoe:] With the wind.
It is high. It is deep. And it is…
- Mmm.
- [Lefkoe:] And it went out in the 1s,
giving you plus-seven.
Now we need to talk to Clint about the hang time.
- OK.
- But I think your placement was great.
- [Love:] Mmm.
Man, that car probably got a dent over there for real.
[Inhaling sharply]
- [​​Oldenburg:] It's always good to see a drill straight
outta Madden like the coffin corner.
- One of my favorites.
- So that's fun.
Gives us a lot of information.
So average hang time 3.3,
about a second lower than the NFL average.
- OK, so still pretty good.
- Still pretty good.
A couple of shanks in there.
So while we didn't get the full increase
on these things, we are gonna be
able to go up a little bit.
We're going plus-nine in kick power, [Ding]
plus-nine in kick accuracy. [Ding]
A little bit of a jump.
- Yeah.
- Nice to see some punting.
- Hopefully if the Packers need a punter
in a pinch, they got a guy.
♪♪♪
- I love myself a mobile quarterback,
and Jordan Love is just that guy.
Being able to get out of the pocket
with somebody to evade
the people on the defensive
line is always huge in Madden.
Now, one thing that I did
notice was his throw under pressure
seemed a little bit low—
only at an 80 overall.
If his throw under pressure
was just a little bit better,
we might be able to get that off
a little bit more accurate.
♪♪♪
- This one is one that
I think we can improve today,
so I'm curious on the
rating: throw under pressure.
- That's probably like a 72.
Gotta be something low.
- It's an 80.
[Madden fans cheering]
But...I think we can get that into the mid-80s.
- I hope so.
♪♪♪
- We have a drill that's gonna cool ya off.
This was your brainchild.
Are you excited to see him go through it?
- I am, yeah. I think that this could
stimulate some things.
So, we're gonna throw some water
balloons at you in the pocket.
We're gonna squirt
some water guns at you and have you throw
at some specific targets
in the form of bottles. See how you do with that.
- All right. Can't wait.
- OK. Let's do it.
- Let's go.
- Yes. He's rising.
[Sarcastically:] Nice glasses. Sweet look.
- Yeah.
- You excited for the reason
you have them on?
It's OK if you say no.
- Yeah, not as excited about that.
I appreciate you sacrificing your body for this.
- Hoping they're not coming for me today.
We'll see.
- They are. We've paid them
literally to come for you today.
So, good luck.
- All right.
- OK.
- We'll see.
- I'm gonna stay dry.
- Yeah.
- Whenever you're ready, Jordan.
- All right.
[Whistle]
Hut.
♪♪♪
- [Lefkoe:] Oh!
- Come on. That's trash.
- How we feelin'? How is this as a drill?
- It's tough, man.
- Do I need to call up LaFleur?
- This might need to be a practice drill.
- OK.
[Whistle]
- Here we go.
♪♪♪
- [Lefkoe:] Ooh. Ooh. Ooh. Ooh!
- [Oldenburg:] That was good avoidance.
- [Love:] Got one. There we go.
- [Lefkoe:] Oh! Everything about that was perfect!
- [Love:] That was the one right there.
- [Oldenburg:] That was nice.
- I loved that. That was great.
- [Oldenburg:] He avoided almost all the water on that.
- [Lefkoe:] Wow. You know, I have heard stories
about men walking on water.
That was as equally as impressive as that.
- Yeah. That was impressive.
- [Lefkoe:] All right.
We're going for the second bottle now.
- Second bottle? All right.
♪♪♪
- [Lefkoe:] Oooh!
- [Oldenburg:] Right in the back.
- [Lefkoe] Wow. That was a blindside sack right there.
- Bro, that one got me.
- That was Danielle Hunter around
the edge. That one was tough.
[Lefkoe:] Man, he drilled him right in the back.
- [Love:] I get one more. I gotta hit this thing.
- All right, Jordan, you got this one.
- Come on.
[Whistle]
♪♪♪
[Glass breaking]
[Screaming]
- That's cold.
- Don't step there. There's glass.
Jordan Love is breaking things.
What did you think?
- That was a hard drill.
I mean, pocket presence on that, his first hit—
that was perfect.
- Yes.
- But just his ability to move around
the pocket looked really good.
And then we got really small targets,
really hard to hit 'em.
But he did get two.
- Yes.
- So, pretty impressive. Based on what we saw
for throw under pressure,
you're gonna go up one point, from 80 to 81.
- Nice. Kick power went up nine.
Kick accuracy went up nine.
We just got throw under pressure to go up one.
I have one simple question
now for you, Mr. Clint Oldenburg:
Jordan Love, is he underrated?
- Jordan Love, you're a smidge underrated.
♪♪♪
You came out and showed us some things
we wanted to see today,
so you went up a little bit. Excited to see more.
- Nice.
- He got soaking wet for us, Clint.
- I did.
- And we appreciate it, too. You're welcome.
- Thank you.
- Damn. Proud of you.
- Twin.